gut dass die krone varianten inzwischen
nicht mehr nach den ländern benannt
werden indem sie zum ersten mal
nachgewiesen wurden am anfang der
pandemie war das ja noch so denn sonst
hieße omikron jetzt wohl die
südafrikanische variante denn in dem
staat am kap der guten hoffnung und
seinen nachbarländern übernahmen omikron
bereits im november das kommando
kennzeichen äußerst rasche verbreitung
und teilweise umgehung des durchimpfung
aufgebauten immun schutzes doch
anscheinend ist dort das gröbste bereits
überwunden aus südafrika ist uns jetzt
der virologe zugeschaltet der die
omikron variante mit entdeckt hat
wolfgang kaiser von der stellenbosch
universität in der nähe von kapstadt
schönen guten morgen dorthin guten
morgen
dann beginnen wir einmal in einigen
teilen südafrikas entspannt sich die
lage etwas ist denn der höhepunkt der
welle in südafrika damit überschritten
oder wie schätzen sie das ein
ja ich glaube das können wir
mittlerweile sagen wir hatten das schon
gesehen in der provinz gauteng
vergangene woche wo diese omikron bälle
angefangen hat dass da die fälle die
fallzahlen wieder runter gegangen sind
das zeigt sich jetzt auch in den anderen
provinzen man muss ja immer vorsichtig
sein über die feiertage wird weniger
getestet und auch verzögert gemeldet
aber ich bin recht zuversichtlich dass
wir das überwunden haben und bin vor
allen dingen froh dass wir sehen dass
die krankenhausaufnahmen insbesondere
die schwersten verläufe
tatsächlich nicht in dem maße ansteigen
wie wir das befürchtet hatten also ganz
klar omikron ist hoch ansteckend kann
einen immunschutz durchimpfung aber auch
durch vorausgegangene infektion
unterlaufen also leute wieder infizieren
oder natürlich bruch infektion
hervorrufen aber der klinische verlauf
ist vermutlich auch deswegen weil man
weil eben viele eine gewisse grund die
täter haben weniger schwer und das ist
natürlich ein großer trost wir hatten
befürchtet dass nach der beta welle die
ja auch die sozialen die erste
südafrikanische variante war vor gut
einem jahr wir wieder vor katastrophalen
zuständen stehen das scheint nicht der
fall wir blicken hier in deutschland
natürlich mit großem interesse auf die
erkenntnisse dienen sie die sie in
südafrika sammeln können aus ihrer
erfahrung können sie das vielleicht noch
einmal ganz konkret beschreiben schützt
aktuell eine zweifach-impfung für
omicron oder gibt es ausreichenden
schutz nur mit der dreifach impfung
ich würde sogar einen schritt weiter
gehen und sagen selbst mit der dreifach
impfung und wir haben das hier gezeigt
anhand einer gruppe deutsche reisende
die ihre booster impfung schon hatten
und dennoch mit omikron infiziert wurden
also omikron kann tatsächlich die
immunantwort unterlaufen aber das heißt
nicht dass die impfungen keinen wert
haben im gegenteil wir nehmen sehr an
dass es diese grund immunität die zwar
eine infektion nicht verhindern kann
aber das ist die ist tief vor einer
schweren erkrankung schützt also man
muss tatsächlich sagen ja die impfung
ist das was uns aus der mikrowelle
herausholt sie haben ja auch schon
gesagt sie würden zitat mit sehr großer
sorge auf deutschland blicken was
omikron angeht warum diese große sorge
und was ist hier anders als
möglicherweise in südafrika
südafrika sind einfach weitaus mehr als
die hälfte der der person bereits hatten
schon omikron dass das zeigen jetzt
antikörper untersuchung und schätzung
gehen sofort 60 bis 80 prozent also sehr
viele leute und man darf nicht vergessen
das ist herzlich so die harmlose
natürliche immunität sondern das
bedeutet dass wir sehr viele menschen
hatten die an womit gestorben sind also
dass der preis ist natürlich ein sehr
hoher aber wir vermuten das ist eben
diese teilweise immunität aufgrund
vorausgegangener infektion oder auch
impfung
440 prozent oder so der bevölkerung der
erwachsenen bevölkerung sind
mittlerweile hierzulande das ist das ist
was vor schweren verläufen schützen ich
mache mir sorgen um das viertel oder so
der deutsch insbesondere aus den
risikogruppen da sind wohl weniger die
noch nicht geimpft sind und sicherlich
größtenteils auch noch nicht genesen
sind dann an dieser stelle zum abschluss
würden wir sie noch bitten um einen
ausblick für die pandemie in 2022 was
erwartet uns da jetzt
es ist immer schwer zu sagen mit solchen
prognosen meistens daneben also ich
hoffe dass das wir
auf der welt in die richtung gehen die
südafrikaner jetzt einschreitet wir
haben zum beispiel die quarantäne jetzt
abgeschafft offiziell wir haben eine
verkürzte isolierung für infizierte die
erkrankt sind wir sehen das ganze jetzt
sehr viel leichter und bewegen uns mit
großen schritten richtung einer in dem i
das heißt man wird zwar infiziert man
wird dann eine erkältungskrankheit
eigentliche symptomatik haben aber weil
eben den risikogruppen größtenteils
immunisiert sind wird es nicht mehr
katastrophalen ausführung kommen ich
wünsche jedem land das es sich leisten
kann dieses stadium durch impfungen zu
erreichen und nicht durch durchgemachte
infektion wir drücken natürlich weiter
fest die darum für alle professor
wolfgang kaiser von der state
universität in der nähe von kapstadt
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch danke dagegen